the most successful people I know have
also failed more than just about anybody
I know and it's this is a really
important lesson if you ever want to
succeed in life successful people tend
to fail at more things than their
critics ever even try and pride which is
the queen of vice and the deadliest of
the seven deadly sins Pride talks in our
ear and says hey don't do this thing you
might fail at it so don't even try just
it'll be so humiliating if it'll be such
a wound to your pride if you if you try
and fail at something
successful people just ignore that voice
and just try things and they often will
throw spaghetti at the wall think about
how many companies Trump has failed at
or Elon Musk has failed at